Well, that's the only thing you will
like.
So, thanks for staying so long. Uh, I I
don't know. This is I I'll show you the
Oh, does it work?
>> Yeah. So, so what is this talk about and
what what it's not about? So I I kind of
didn't even plan to give a serious talk
here. I thought this will be more like a
working meeting here. Uh and when I
learned that I'm supposed to give a
talk, I have given like five propaganda
talks this year alone and and last year
in Paris around this time I I gave this
long long long talk at Indria. So if you
have a if you want to see a well
organized propaganda talk just just
click on that and don't don't watch
don't listen to me don't listen to me
now and uh I I would also say that I
will not speak about formalization
because Adrian already talked about what
we are now doing with ATLA which is
quite a nice uh project which I like
And I think on the next slide there
there is a pointer to a auto history of
auto formalization talk that I gave last
last year at the tester bone. Uh, and I
must say
I I I find myself to to
some in some weird face transition from
from being a big propaganda guy about
combining machine learning and theorem
proving to being kind of a contrarian
saying that uh maybe you guys are
trusting uh some some of these hypes uh
too much and maybe you should be doing
more rigorous science rather than some
startup uh pitches. So, so you will
probably be able to to to to see where I
am from from from these few few remarks.
One one one thing is that like the
history of my propaganda talks goes way
back and and one of as serious ones was
actually done here at instit
when homotopy type theory was old older
age and nobody knew anything about
machine learning. So, so if you if you
want to have some historical comparison
with 11 years ago, you can click click
on these slides
and like there are other pointers here
just for the fun like the these are the
AITP challenges and bets that I declared
at IHP in 2014
uh in in this propaganda talk. So, so I
at that time we could we we just had the
kind of fresh results with Tesar
Kalishik mostly that we could prove like
40% of the fly spec and misar level
lamas automatically by combining uh
theorem pro with machine learning in
various ways. So, so my bet like these
are actually bets for real money for€
10,000 euros uh was that in 20 years
with the same resources that's the big
caveat which nobody seems to understand
these days we will be able to prove
twice as many uh 80%
and in 10 years 60%. So, so we actually
did that in like 2021
and there is the the last one is this
kind of auto formalization. Uh but so
this is just when we started to develop
the first learning based systems for
autoformmalization.
uh that 25 years from 2014 50%
of the top level statements in latte
written master level math curriculum
textbooks will be parsed automatically
and with correct formal uh semantics and
I I think that there is kind of enough
push for auto formalization especially
with language models that this may
really go faster than I expected but
well whatever. So, so
the my my history is that back in like
almost 30 years ago, I was looking at uh
how how can people automate math because
it was somehow implicitly
um understood at the time that
mathematics is the language of science
and we have this kind of embedding of
mathematics into logic. And in principle
we could uh we could thus uh transform
all all our problems to logic and solve
them by uh theorem proving right. So
this this was like some of the early AI
ideas and like like I was looking at
what these automated theorem proving
people are doing and I wasn't totally
excited about
uh about the
the the way they were doing it because
of the combinatorial explosion they were
immediately getting when working with
large theories. So, so basically I I
tried in my master thesis to to get some
reasonably big corpus of a human like uh
mathematics that I could feed to to some
theorroving system and learn the
heristics that the uh that the humans uh
are uh following. and this was the plan
and it was it mostly kind of stayed the
plan like like it was a very daunting
task to to do for all sorts of reasons.
uh but like uh this was basically the
the master plan I declared u 20 years
ago
and I I wonder how it's today related to
to to to your project right like to to
to Malinka
uh
because like for for example at that
time
the the the kind of learning approach
could could be seen as an alternative to
to to to this flagship AI project of
ducklanut in in the US which was like
let's just write the heristic down
manually right like all the heristics
for problem solving like like well okay
maybe if you if you have a lot of
funding you will get a lot of people to
write down a lot of problem solving
horistics but then how do you combine
them right like you so so it it felt to
me that somehow So all sorts of learning
need need to be involved in various ways
and it seems to me that to to today like
obviously with the
ascent of the statistical machine
learning it's it's kind of believed by
more and more people that uh maybe too
much that we will we will learn this all
just uh from from from the data. Uh so
so that's kind of an introduction and
then now there will be a series of
various random remarks. So so one thing
that also relates quite a bit to to the
history of ATP.
Uh actually what triggered me was
Adrian's talk when when he said that
ATPs are today amazingly good in
geometry for example. uh so I actually
did 10 years ago I I ran uh the
state-of-the-art automated theorem
previous on Tarski and geometry on the
problems that Michael Bison and Larry
Walsh
uh were
creating uh according to this f Tarski
book and the state-of-the-art theorem
provers couldn't solve it all and
neither could Bon and walls they they
introduced a guiding method But that was
kind of a cheating cheating method that
kind of allowed them to uh to to get
Otter to kind of formally do the proof,
but but it was kind of a human uh human
guided uh proof. But like the the way
uh Adrianne mentioned mentioned it
actually leads to interesting uh history
of automated uh deduction. So, so this
is taken from Martin Davis uh paper
early history of automated deduction
where he very nicely distinguishes
uh between these two two camps or two
paths which really formed in automated
theorem proving and one is kind of the
log logicians the logicists the people
who come up with different calcul and
typically with um uh better and better
calculate, better and better you could
say symmetry breaking rules like like
ways how to prevent the the calculate to
be super redundant and to be more
efficient and and he like he doesn't
explicitly speak about machine learning.
this this probably wasn't the the idea
at the time but like what he speaks
about in the second camp are the kind of
horistic people right like let's do it
like humans like Simon and new like
let's try to like this duck approach
also let's try to write down the the
problem serving solving heristics and
what is funny like again you can think
about it in today's context with these
LLMs uh eating everything which is
available out there that in in this
paper it was written I think for the
handbook in 2000. He says the difficulty
with the first approach was that
available information about how creative
mathematicians go about their business
was and remains vague and anecdotal. So
is this better today? like uh like I
think Tim G had this idea to to write
the
how how do they call that uh informed
proofs or uh some something like proofs
annotated with actually how how the
mathematician
makes various decisions. But you could
also say
that this is today kind of learnable,
right? like that to today we have so
much material out there both in the
informal and maybe more and more in the
formal world that if you kind of jump on
the machine learning bandwagon
this sentence of Martin Davis isn't
anymore such a such a big deal right so
so that's kind of interesting to think
about it in in this uh the the the the
kind of thing that triggered me when I
uh when I heard Adrian to to uh mention
this this geometry is that actually
geometry according to Martin Davis in in
in this uh early deduction history is is
is the thing that led Robinson
to to to basically
uh start thinking about her brand
universe as the important important
thing in automated theorem proving and
uh the the there is like a very direct
analogy that he came up between like the
geometry solvers and the generalized
theorem proving like like the the
geometry the the way Galantra
did his geometry machine or whatever it
was is is kind of a special case of what
you do when you are basically solving
arbit arbitrary logical problems and we
have a name for it which is which is
this herbrant universe and that's what
these ATP people have been have been
doing for for decades now. So, so it's
it's like an example of something which
which is very humanly accessible and and
maybe natural even on one hand like
geometry, right? Like we have all these
geometrical intuions and stuff and
something which suddenly becomes like
very logical and abstract and uh like if
you start speaking about a brand
universe in a room full of machine
learning people they will switch off
immediately right like this is not what
the LLM people are doing. Uh
so uh I would say
the this distinction that Davis did is
to me at least extremely relevant still
today.
Uh so for example the talk that AA gave
was was basically about these orderings
which aren't extremely powerful symmetry
breaking methods in uh today's automated
theorem proofs like like vampire
and uh like uh similarly in subsolvers
you you have so many so advanced
symmetry breaking methods and you have
even something that they call close
learning right and uh it's It's really
very interesting to to think about how
to combine all all these like very smart
human engineered uh ideas, methods,
calculi with various kinds of machine
learning and I should give credit to to
the Munich group like Stefan Schulz and
Densinger and others who really thought
about it a lot already uh 19 uh 90s.
Uh so so I I just because I started to
talk about Martin Davis I will randomly
jump to to speaking about this
particular thing that we did quite
recently mostly with yellow people in
Brock. So, so it's like if you put
yourself into the fully machine learning
believer camp, uh what what you could do
today to solve basically all these very
hard problem which are I don't know in
TPD,
Isabel, Sledgehammer, Misar, what what
whatever
is take take a first order problem in in
any of these uh data sets and
benchmarks.
And if you have infinitely precise
guessing power, just create the the the
precise ground instances of these first
order closes and give it to a s solver.
The s solver is not the issue. The s
solver is super human, super powerful
and has been superhuman and super
powerful for like two two decades uh at
least. So, so the the kind of question
is is the machine learning so powerful
right uh so so we uh we tried to test
this uh particular it's it's like Martin
Davis today right like Martin Davis
after uh 60 years or so uh can can we
come up with reasonable machine learning
architecture that will we will train it
on some proofs and how how the first
order clauses get instantiated there to
to get the propositional problem that is
then easily solved by the S solver and
and then can can the trained
architecture propose instantiations for
like like new problems that we uh throw
throw at it. So, so like like if you're
interested, read read this paper. the
the upshot is kind of yes but kind of
not so much yet at least like we are
definitely not better than than the
standard instantiation
uh based theorem previous and their
horistics in in this particular way
which is like very ambitious like you
look at the first order clause with
quantifiers and and you ask some chad
GPT or whatever maybe just GP PT uh now
please produce the ground terms that you
should pluck into into into this clause
uh for for for these variables. Uh so so
what yellow edit is is an architecture
which is
different from what most the language
modeling people are doing today in the
sense that it's signature symbol
independent.
uh and that's for a good reason because
in in in these problems there are
typically many autogenerated scholum
uh symbols and the the way these symbols
are uh autogenerated is inconsistent
between uh different problems. So, so if
you started to trust the names in the in
the way how how the transformer
architecture kind of trusts the names,
you you would get very inconsistent data
to train on. And actually, if we do like
kind of a reasonably fair comparison
uh between the transformer and this
anonymous GNN to RNN architecture, then
the anonymous architecture beats the
transformer. I I should say that we we
haven't tried like these newer heavy uh
chain of thought uh reasoning models on
this. Uh but then then again it's it's a
question of the of the resources right
like when once you start using the heavy
uh chain of thought models you you
somehow need to compare it with the
resources that you invest in into like
this architecture that uh yell at it.
One one other remark which kind of plugs
back to to this logistic versus the
heristic or learning uh people is that
the this particular approach that we
started to do was very very
significantly improved when we instead
of just calling a solver which means
giving
which means that you have to instantiate
also all the clauses is that encode uh
equality in typically in these
instantiation based theorem previous you
you really do it in a way where you have
axioms for symmetry transitivity
reflexivity and congruence of equality
and that's fine like you you can uh you
can do it that way you can
you can try to instantiate these clauses
but typically to to solve these problems
you you really need to instantiate many
of these clauses because equality is
like very prominent in in a lot of these
programs. And if you instead of that go
with a slightly smarter uh approach
which in in this case means just calling
the the kind of well-known decision
procedure for uh ground clauses with
equality then then suddenly you your
task is much much easier because you are
now supposed to guess maybe only half or
maybe even less of the instantiations of
of the first other clauses. Uh so so
this this was really like a big uh um uh
performance boost that we did just by by
being smarter on on the logic side like
like trivially smarter and not kind kind
of relying so much on the machine
learning side because the machine
learning side really wasn't uh super uh
super smart as I thought it would be
interesting to try it with the more
heavy duty reasoning models today like
the the the way we we kind of do these
things today are are these kind of
learning proving feedback loops like
this this particular experiment and
that's like one thing that I like like I
said initially back in 1996
my my thinking was well let's just try
to learn from the human math textbooks
etc and like I I I Somewhere in the back
of my mind there was the idea that we
will kind of combine it with the uh
reasoning and deduction etc. Uh a bit
like uh I guess this guy is talking
about in in his book called uh science
and method.
Uh and I uh I guess I was really uh
surprised when I really started to do
it. So, so I I did the first system
which really does this feedback loop
between proving and learning
uh like 10 years later in 2006 this
machine learning for automated reasoning
malaria
and like it was um surprising how how
much
uh it can really how far it can really
go in this kind of self-learning uh
feedback loop between between the
proving and learning. Uh the the the one
issue with it which again may be
relevant today for kind kind of the LLM
camp which tries to in the extreme case
get rid fully of the formal proof is
that I really had to debug my
translation of the misar library to to
first the theorem pro a lot because like
the the the machine learning technology
is very lazy, greedy, like this is a
well-known fact uh repeated over and
over in the history of AI. If you have
some very simple patterns that your
learning method can learn from, they
will kind of hang on or catch on th
those patterns rather than being forced
to to to do the hard stuff. So, so for
example, when I had still like a
slightly inconsistent translation of
misar to first logic, the these
self-arning feedback loops
would kind of devolve because they would
catch on the inconsistencies the the the
very small number of inconsistencies
which I had there would become very
permanent once you once you start
working with a greedy lazy uh machine
learning system. So, so I I kind of
debugged it for Mizar and like Larry
Pollson got interested back in 2007 and
sent me his is problems and he had like
I think three different translations at
the time and one of them was sound and
that was the most efficient for the
normal automated theorem previous like
vampire e pass etc and so he naively
sent me sent me those problems because
he was interested in the performance
improvement
And and like this this um this beast has
solved all his quote unquote hard
problems in like 10 20 minutes by by
finding the the single well single the
the the easiest unoundness that he had
there which happened to be present in
all the problems and then trivially sol
solving on on on his pro all all of his
problems because once it knows how to
exploit the it will always go go after
that. Uh so
uh and and the interesting thing is that
with the non-learning systems you don't
get that like like his translation was
still very useful to the standard
automated theorem previous who who
didn't have this learning capacity
because it was kind of unnatural for
them to to exploit uh the unsoldness uh
there. So um I'm I'm saying this
uh like for for the last let's say 20
years uh I I have been doing a a lot of
these fe feedback loops and always
beating my collaborators and students
uh telling them like you you really need
to make it right otherwise the system
will devolve like like in in these cases
which I heard hard about uh in the
beginnings but it seems to me today that
the LLM people are kind of going in the
direction like if you if you look at
this Deep Mind OpenAI latest
breakthroughs in solving IMO just just
with the language model apparently like
obviously nobody knows anything about
it. So, so maybe uh it's it's it's just
uh apparently that there there is no
formal proofing. Uh so I don't know like
maybe the language models can really be
pushed to be so critical of the
supposed proof that they will reject it
and that they will kind of behave as a
as a proof checker. But but I don't know
how how how far this can be pushed. I
I'm kind of really really interested in
uh whe whether this will scale to kind
of new math etc. Uh
um yeah. So so as I said like the the
these feedback loops are for for me one
of the most interesting things that we
are today doing and I think they they
can be done both in the kind of human
friendly math settings and also in like
these very human unfriendly settings.
So, so, so one thing I did quite early
because it was very uh productive was
for example a similar feedback loop for
evolving strategies for automated
theorem previous uh where um you you are
evolving something which is kind of
symbolic and which is kind of guiding
the automated theorem pre but it's it's
a program for the automated theorem.
it's not something very uh human
friendly. Uh what what may be kind of
more human friendly was when we really
started to seriously look at um internal
guidance of automated theorem previous.
So for example in Tableau previous in
specifically in connection tableau the
calculus is kind of human friendly. You
kind of always operate on on something
relatively small like this partial
connected tableau and you you kind of
feed it to your machine learner whatever
there's some graph neural network and uh
the graph neural network is supposed to
do this kind of Monte Carlo research
like in the alpha go alpha zero uh
systems and maybe
grow some human friendly intuitions like
is this um is is should should I play
this move or should I play this move? Is
this tableau close to completion or is
this tableau uh something uh uh that
that will not succeed uh for a for a
long time? So, so that may be one one
example of a relatively human friendly
proof uh setting uh that can be guided
by machine learning. Then the there is
the internal guidance of of these
state-of-the-art automated theorem
provers like these saturation provers
like vampire and e-ro like in these
enigma and deepire systems where again
it's it's kind of very
uh yeah I I don't know whether we can
call these uh things to be very very
human friendly proof but yeah they they
they are really the state-of-the-art
today and then obviously there there's
this whole business of guiding tactical
persist which probably started with this
tactic to system by Tibotia
which which is really seems to be to
today like the the preferred direction
for for the deep learning community
because it's sufficiently high level. it
very uh it it's fits reasonably like the
language modeling situation because you
uh you can do all sorts of stuff.
Uh so so that that may be like like the
the the kind of most human uh related
proving and I already mentioned like
these instantiation prover. So, so what
I what I what I showed you before was
like this uh very ambitious setting
where we really synthesize the ground
instances of the first order clauses.
You could do the same for high order
clauses if you are super ambitious. Uh
but like what you can also do is to
guide the instantiation processes
of the instantiation based provers like
I pro CVC5. So, so that actually works
better and that's also interesting like
it it's somehow shows
that uh so for example what we did
recently when we got like a 20%
improvement in CVC5 over the misar data
set we we really just guide the we we
tell CVC5 which of the clauses in its
current proof search it should um try to
instantiate but We don't tell it how it
should instantiate them. We we kind of
leave it up to CVC5 smartness to to use
all of its uh carefully
um invented methods to to decide how to
instantiate and we just give it kind of
this very high level instruction. Yeah.
Now now instantiate uh this particular
clause. So, so, so again like like it
shows you
the kind of what what works right like
here we can improve state-of-the-art SMT
solver by 20% if we do it in in a
reasonable not super ambitious way
whereas we we cannot really improve it
if we do it in the very ambitious way
when we try to generate the ground
instances uh ourselves
Um yeah so I just wanted to show you one
example of of this proving learning uh
feedback loop like this is kind of
canonical uh for for me like we did it
in 2019
uh by putting some kind of machine
learning guidance into into eer. So
that's this enigma system and and the
way it works is that you start with some
15,000 proofs that eware can solve
without any guidance in 10 seconds. Then
you train in this case some gradient
boosted decision trees which are
reasonably fast and efficient. you plug
them back into the uh e- priv and once
you have them there they help you guide
eery in a smarter way and then you solve
more problems in in the kind of second
operation and then you train it again
and then you solve more problems etc. So
so if you if you do this about six times
it gives you 70% improvement and the
very very important thing here is that
we don't cheat. So, so this is all done
on a single CPU in 10-second uh CPU
time. So, this is really apples to
apples comparison with the
with the other methods that people uh
develop in automated theorem proving
like if you if you push it further, we
we eventually got to to the 75%
u in 2021.
and and this is kind of the the the the
kind of victorious email that I wrote
when we uh when we reached the 75%.
So again like just to as as a comment to
to the thing that started let's say in
with with the LLM
uh people like like you you can do like
very very strong things without uh LLMs
right like uh this this is before LLMs
uh and like there there is more of it so
so there is like for example this deep
architecture
which goes even more radical than for
example this enigma guidance. I I will
not go into the details in how how
little information it collects for the
machine learning and how efficiently it
uses it for uh for for the guidance of
of the theorem.
Uh
yeah, I'll probably skip uh I I I should
say another thing which people for their
own uh shame uh do not know much about
is the amazing work done by Bob Verof
and Michael Kenyon and JD Phillips and
and this community uh over open problems
in equal algebra and the these are
really proofs of open conjectures in
let's say quasi group and loop theory uh
which reach like 200,000
uh inferences like like Bob very freely
has proofs that are crazy crazy long and
what he uh called it is the hints method
or hints guidance and what I call it is
symbolic machine learning uh so he he
doesn't like me saying that he does
machine learning uh but I think it's
appropriate
Like I I so what he does is like a
clever human guided theory exploration
when he when he creates many related
problems. So some of them are easier,
some of them become harder and harder
and as he solves the easier problems he
extracts hints from from the proofs and
and these are basically just the lemas
in in the proofs and then he use these
lemas as some kind of islands islands of
safety when when he goes from the exoms
to to the conjecture in the kind of
harder uh theory harder problem. He he
knows that when he arrived at at some of
these lemas that were useful in the
easier problem, for example, when the
theory had some additional uh exm in it,
uh he knows that he can kind of assume
that this is a good thing and that he
could that he can focus on inferencing
with with this lema that he he now
achieved. So it's obviously not 100%
there. There is a lot of interesting
technology in it. Uh but it's really
like an amazing uh symbolic I I call it
symbolic uh learning guidance for
today's automated theorem which really
lead uh today's automated theorem pros
to to solve open conjectures. Uh and
it's it's a shame that people don't know
about it. It's it's really one of the
biggest uh achievements of automated
theorem proving. Uh I also wanted to
mention like very recent this is this
year at cade
uh very on vampire by Martin Sura. So so
he he basically by by doing this like
very efficient symbol independent
machine learning which slows down
vampire only by 30%. like this. This
runs on a CPU. Again, this is all very
precise, rigorous uh comparison of the
unguided uh vampire with respect to the
number of CPU instructions. Uh so, so he
slows it down only by 30% by by having
like very nicely integrated uh efficient
neural neural networks into vampire. and
he made 20 20%
uh improvement on the test set on on
TPTP after he improved it by different
methods by the strategy evolution
methods by 27% in cask uh last year. So,
so, so like again like you you don't
read these things in the quant nature
what whatever but these are really
amazing uh improvements that are that
are happening. Uh
uh yeah. So, so by the way, he he solved
uh several problems in TPTP where people
even didn't know whether what their
status is supposed to be, whether they
are supposed to be provable or counter
satisfiable and he proved quite a few
problems where people
assume that they know the status but no
automated theorem pro was uh was able to
prove them. Yeah. And it it would be
interesting like like yeah take take one
of these IMO trained LLMs and try that
right or one one of these deep seeks
like these reasoning LLMs today's and
and try to see whether whether you can
you can do the same and with what
resources uh so this is
uh this is the architecture just to show
you a bit of the details. So he he has
like in the very beginning he throws the
initial clauses in the program to this
symbol in the independent graph neural
network and it gives him initial
embeddings for the symbols and for the
clauses and then he has two like very
fast tightly integrated recursive neural
networks. one he calls generalized
weight and one he calls generalized age
because this is some automated theorem
proving tradition which um like
basically each time you create a new
term you you apply some like very quick
uh neural layer just basically just once
because you already have the embeddings
of the uh argument uh symbols and you
you basically just apply the the one
step uh of the recursive neural network
which kind of takes these arguments and
uh makes uh the embedding of the new
term which with with its head uh
operator. So, so this is like a
operation that is done each time a new
term is created and and which is done
like very efficiently in this way like
it's basically integrated with the term
data structures in in vampire and the
generalized weight works similarly for
uh clauses. So, so it's some kind of
like very uh fast uh neural network that
ranks uh the the clauses.
Um yeah. So, so this was about like
these low-level ATP guided things. I I
wanted to also uh again in this Malinka
uh natural language etc. uh context
discuss like this kind of dream with
which I kind of was infected some 30
years ago and and like this LLM dream
that emerged I would say in the minds of
many people when Chad GPT got released
and they discovered uh machine learning
and I I I'm still kind of thinking uh
how how these two um worlds
um connect and uh interact and and um
work together. So, so you probably all
know here the QED manifesto like it was
this project to build like the formal uh
encyclopedia of all math knowledge and
techniques and they have these quotes by
GD that I don't know math will basically
reduce to to logic and then by white hat
that uh math understanding will be all
of the understanding ing right. So, so
if you if you take him seriously, you
would say we will will move from Reddit
discussions or Twitter discussions to to
mathematical discussions, right? like I
I don't know whether we are succeeding
in in in that and then there is like
this is also in the Q manifesto this is
the quote uh by the the Brown
uh again like about like this uh the
this idea of creating like this crazy
formal encyclopedia of all mathematical
knowledge and as somebody pointed out It
kind of goes to back to piano. Uh so
um
they they do have some comments about AI
but they are kind of mostly negative in
the the QED manifesto. Uh so so they are
saying uh that uh like you can but don't
have to build this uh database of math
um with AI whatever they meant by AI at
the time maybe they even meant automated
theorem proving by by as AI at the time
uh and
uh I I think the the interesting point
is that they insisted on on this kind of
formal proofing aspect there like they
they are kind of agnostic but but saying
whatever it is is it produced by a
machine by a holistic by a human uh it
should be checkable and that will be
this kind of consistency uh layer that
uh we will have and yeah again like we
we kind of don't have it today for kind
of the LLM dream, right? Like for for
this one uh big um internet eaten eaten
by the llams today.
And uh the the other uh kind of
remark
which I wanted to u speak about a bit is
like what what are the analogies and
differences between how for example
especially this reasoning
uh LLMs that emerged relatively recently
um have compared to the automated TRM
previous. So I I was actually asked by
journalist uh recently. Uh so so I think
you you probably all
uh know some of these things but uh um
may maybe not uh completely. So, so I
would say like if you if you think about
what a language model is, if it's
totally untrained, it's it's a token
prediction generated model and it will
just generate strings, right? And the
the way how I explained to the
journalist what an ATP is because
everybody now knows about what kind of
LLMs are is that it's kind of an LLM uh
but it's constrained by logic, right?
like it's uh it can also produce a huge
amount of junky clauses etc. Uh but like
we know that those junky clauses at
least follow from from the from the
previous clauses and in the kind of
untrained situations
these are this is the only difference
right like the LLM is producing
arbitrary strings the the ITP is
producing arbitrary clauses. Now uh like
we can obviously put some statistical
guidance like like in in the case of
neural language models we put a neural
network there. In the case of automated
theorem pro is again like we can put for
example a graph neural network etc. So,
so, so, so one way how to understand the
the kind of modern ATPs as
with with a maybe big grain of salt as
basically logic constraint LLMs, right?
Like you you could kind of um uh do it
uh like that and then start quarreling
with the LLM people. uh
and uh yeah well then there is the
training
uh well one one funny thing is how how
all all these concept emerge in the deep
learning community so what we have been
calling premise selection since like
2003 when reasoning over these large uh
knowledge bases like misar Isabel
Flyspec etc uh the the the LLM people
started to call retrieval augmented
generation
at around 2020 and the the the idea it's
it's again like one interesting analogy
there if you give to the automated
theorem prover the whole misar or Isabel
library its chance of getting the proof
is really really low like if you if you
don't if you aren't reasonably smart uh
in the kind of selection of the
knowledge the performance devolves a lot
apparently this this also works for the
LLM so so if you if you give it the
right facts to to focus on then it's
kind of inference whatever that means
also go goes up quite a bit. So um uh
it's it's kind of interesting to think
about like initially like like the the
the way the kind of LLM
uh maximalists were talking about it
well we we will just eat it all and it
will do the right thing but apparently
not right like apparently the the
prompting with with the right um
relevant uh knowledge uh helps a lot uh
the
similar I think
are are these feedback loops like you
you didn't see it so much before
Deepseek but I think with the Deepseek
uh publication it really became out out
in in the open that you you can uh train
the LLMs in in this kind of
reinforcement learning loop where you
have some solution of the mathematical
problem in the end for example some
number which is kind of unlikely to
reach and you maybe have some kind of
curriculum of problems like easier and
harder and and somehow the kind of LLM
uh gets there by having basically all of
the world's knowledge and learning how
to use this world's knowledge for a
proof search like you you could call it
some something like uh proof search
uh so I think one um one question and
maybe a research problem for the Malinka
community which occurred to me it's like
maybe at some point like if if we have
like these self-arning loops for for
these very big uh beasts could it could
it be that the LLM will convince itself
like learn from from from these
reinforcement uh learning uh feedbacks
that it's actually good for it to to
follow the rules of logic. Like could it
be that it discovers on its on its own
that uh what whatever it's doing when
when it's um trying to solve the these
uh mathematical problems by by this kind
of tree of thought uh reasoning. uh it
it will actually like emerge from from
that like like the the kind of rules of
uh formal uh proof. So so for for me
this this sounds like an interesting
uh research uh problem. I I don't know
how much time I have. Should I uh start?
>> Five minutes.
>> Five minutes. Okay. So be because this
is about natural language. I I was just
in Poland at the Polish logic congress
and I was in a university where this guy
Stan Slafeshks apparently was a a
recctor um at some point. So, so, so,
um,
this is, um, what the, what the Misar
people did in 1970s was actually take,
uh, the the not the Gensen stuff which
actually came later. Uh but the
Yashkovski stuff uh this uh this paper
that he um that he published in 1934
that is called on the on the rules of uh
suppositions where he basically defines
what the Misari people then started to
call the the declarative uh uh proof
style. Uh
so there there is some history to it. I
think the first person who brought it to
the west was John Harrison who
interacted with the miser guys at the
first Q second Q workshop in Warso and
then obviously Macario Snapro the sub
people etc.
And like one question that I always had
for the linguists which are somehow
present in Malinka
uh which occurred to me like back in
2011 when I employed an approach guy was
is there is there a direct or indirect
link between the rashki style uh natural
deduction and what the linguists call uh
discourse representation uh theory. So,
so, so the way I started to think about
it was that at some point 20 years ago,
I reimplemented the the misar data
structures that do this and then I don't
know six years, seven years after that,
I saw a talk about napro given by Daniel
Kulwine where he called basically the
same data structures in napro
uh he called them discourse
representation uh theory. So some the
there is some link here which maybe
maybe somebody could explore but maybe
it's trivial and everybody everybody
knows that uh what what is interesting
probably for for the Malinka project are
whether the declarative proofs are
somehow
superior for for ATPs for for proof
search for automated proof.
And uh I would say even in the ITP
setting and I pointed it out during
Macario's talk, it's not fully clear
that the declarative proofs are always
preferable. I I think the community is
quite a bit still on the tactical side
rather than on the declarative side. And
I I hear from various people that for
example for the software and hardware
verification the tactical uh proofs are
preferable uh to to the kind of
declarative proof style. One interesting
point made this year at AITP by
Mont Mas Bakshis from the Kimra team was
that they are not better for this
reinforcement learning loop. They do
over lean for IMO but they are easier to
debug for the humans, easier for the
human uh developers.
uh and uh I I don't know like if you if
you want to go in the direction like
five years ago I I did this GPT2
experiments over over the misaria
declarative proofs. My impression at the
time was that GPT was still very bad in
understanding the semantics of of of
these declarative proofs and it was
producing it was a bit similar to to
this Karpatus uh experiment with STS in
where you you produce plausibly looking
mathematically gibberish but the
semantics is is very
uh hard for for the language model. But
this this was in 2020. Obviously, it's
it's unclear how strong
uh the the kind of much bigger uh models
uh are today. again like I would perhaps
argue that if you want to go in that
direction,
you may want to invest in some kind of
better generalizing architectures like
like these anonymous graph neural
networks rather than at the kind of
vanilla transformer architecture which
really relies on the names a lot and if
you rename things it may stop working at
etc. I I would also say that the comment
you would get from the classical
logicist automated theorem proving
people is that this is very distant from
like all these symmetry breaking methods
that the ATP people have shown to be to
be so uh powerful. So so that's another
disadvantage of of trying to do
automated theorem proving by producing
the declarative proofs. And on on that
note, I will just uh mention the the
very recent experiment we did with T and
to some extent Yas by which was
motivated by Serial Cohen's talk in
Sweden. So so we uh and actually
Macarios also mentioned the the problem
of reconstructing sledgehammer proofs in
in Isabel. So, so what we tried with T
is that I gave him 10,000 hammer proofs
for for miser done by Vampire or EP and
he tried to fine-tune this 32 billion
model to to get them to massage them
into a nice beautiful decorative misar
proofs and he he actually gets uh some
successes. I I don't know if I have it
somewhere. Uh yeah, I I don't have the
success rate. So I think it's like he
got now 20 nice misar checkable
declarative proofs out of these horrible
TPT blobs by by running this 32 billion
uh quen model which actually does a lot
of reasoning. So I I I don't want you to
read this, but like this is the output
of the Quen language model when it gets
the the horrible TPT proofs and it kind
of does its own reasoning to come up
with a a readable uh declarative proof.
So, so that's uh maybe maybe one way how
to how to get from from these like
automated proofs to to beautiful human
human friendly proofs fine-tune a large
uh language model. Uh so that's it. uh I
um I don't know like these 30 years ago
I I really thought that it will be
interesting to to start learning theory
proving from humans
and I wonder if I still believe it and
maybe maybe to some extent I I think the
the kind of interacting
with with all all these tools taught me
that the situation is quite a bit richer
and more interesting that the human math
and human proofs aren't everything like
I think the inhuman the the tool
produced the ATP produced the AI
produced proofs will be more and more
prominent
and that's maybe exciting um and there
may be like all these analogies with
things like machines playing chess and O
and if you if you want to hear about
like the the very interesting latest
experiment which we are doing over ois
then come to kick next week in Brazil. I
will I will say about it. Thank you.
So are there questions or or comments
for discussion?
>> Okay,
>> everybody start.
>> Yeah, I mean we can carry on outside of
the room and uh discuss offline. Yes, I
think it's it's very reasonable. So
yes,
so I mean uh I think uh you go Carlos,
Philip and all the people working you
know at the Malinka team, we would like
to thank you. I mean all of you and as
we said at the very beginning like three
days ago we see the project as a you
know way to I mean build a community of
people around I mean Europe the world uh
working on these topics it's really
exciting there are many elements I think
uh you know I mean we saw that this many
elements to combine together at the same
time the feeling of convergence so uh
it's very open and fast evolving so
Yeah. Uh I'm sure we'll meet again soon
in one way or the other. So, thank you.
Yeah.